cette auto école sociale permet aux
bénéficiaires de minima sociaux de
passer leur permis de conduire à tarif
réduit l' agence départementale
d'insertion activity permet quant à elle
d'accompagner et de suivre des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi des actions
financées en partie par le ffs eux
depuis 2015 le département des yvelines
est devenu un organisme intermédiaire et
peut donc gérer le fonds social européen
un fonds dédié à l'emploi
on intervient en subventions et en appui
des différents acteurs de l'insertion
dans le département que ce soient des
acteurs privés des associations des
entreprises d'insertion où le public
là on va intervenir soit auprès
d'autorités locales comme peuvent être
les opci ou les mairies ou bien m nous
mêmes en place des actions d'insertion
toujours en faveur de l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle des yvelinois
au sein de la mission europe
huit personnes sont entièrement dédiés à
la mise en oeuvre du fonds social
européen pour la période 2015 2020 le
département des yvelines a reçu une
enveloppe de 16 millions d'euros
jusqu'à présent près de dix mille
personnes éloignées de l'emploi ont été
accompagnées à l'accès aux fonds
européens peut paraître complexe ça
l'est un peu et tout notre travail c'est
un travail d'accompagnement des porteurs
de projets pour pouvoir faciliter
l'accès à ces fous et leur permettre
d'être plus proches de leur public avec
le fs leur permet de lutter contre
toutes formes de discriminations sur le
marché du travail
d'autres fonds peuvent également être
mobilisées dans le département des
yvelines le feader pour le développement
rural ou encore le feder le fonds
européen de développement régional
depuis deux ans saint quentin en
yvelines fait partie des quinze
territoire iti franciliens c'est tout
six européens permet de mobiliser des
fonds en faveur d'une croissance
innovante lancée en 2010 est le ski cub
a bénéficié d'une subvention de 333 1659
euros donc dès qu'il ya un projet que
l'agglomération identifient comme et
pouvant être financé sur ses fonds
européen plutôt que sur les fronts de
l'agglomération elle-même ce qui est
aussi une manière d'un moment où
l'argent public se fait rare
faire plus de choses et bien
l'agglomération de sélectionne et le
présente à la région autre exemple fin
2018 à montigny le bretonneux près 250
logements pu bénéficier de fonds
européens pour des travaux de rénovation
thermique sur la rénovation thermique
qui est un bon exemple
nous avons un millier de aujourd'hui de
particuliers publiés ici grâce à ces
fonds européens de 2,2 de ted en matière
de rénovation thermique
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
évidemment beaucoup plus loin sur les 5
millions d'euros alloués par l'europe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 30% étaient
jusqu'à présent utilisé